ils sont conducteurs de bus agents de
sécurité employés des pompes funèbres
taxi ou caissiers et dès ce week end ils
vont pouvoir se faire vacciner en tant
que personnels prioritaires
le gouvernement vient d'élargir la liste
des travailleurs de plus de 55 ans qui
ont accès au vaccin
cela concernerait près de 400000
personnes supplémentaires alors les
centres de vaccination vont t'ils croulé
sous les demandes
on fait le point avec florent clavel une
vingtaine de professions prioritaires à
la vaccination
après les enseignants les policiers les
livreurs caissière ou encore conducteurs
de bus j'ai fil bleu cette nouvelle est
la bienvenue même si l'on regrette que
la vaccination ne soit réservé qu'aux
plus de 55 ans c'est une très bonne
annonce
sachant que les conducteurs de bus sont
au contact de la clientèle toute l'année
et huit heures par jour
après ce qui serait bien ce serait de
l'étendre à tout le monde et que la
vaccination ne ne se fasse pas que sur
les personnes de plus de 55 ans qui
représentent environ une dizaine de
pourcents dans notre tenté soit environ
une soixantaine de personnes autres
professions concernées celles des agents
d'entretien ils sont une centaine chez
tour métropole tous âges confondus
pour ce représentant syndical la
vaccination vient trop tard dans la
mesure où elle a la capacité de produire
les vaccins existent on porte a dans le
même temps qu' à aucun effort réel y
compris dans la production de vaccin qui
est fait
donc oui là la vaccination des
travailleurs au général comme des
personnes âgées etc tout est trop tardif
bien sûr à partir de samedi ces salariés
pourront se rendre dans ce centre situé
aux halles de tours ici 450 d'eau sont
réservés aux personnels prioritaires
alors cette mesure at-elle des chances
d'aboutir où la vaccination sera t-elle
bout des premiers signes d'une légère
montée en puissance une centaine de
personnels de l'éducation nationale cet
après midi contre un peu moins de 90 le
week-end dernier
se faire vacciner il faut le faire c'est
le seul moyen je pense pour se sortir de
ce mauvais pas reste à rétablir la
confiance dans le vaccin astrazeneca ce
vaccin dont l'image a été entaché par
quelques cas de thrombose
c'est lui qui utilisaient ici l'asra
zeneca les études sont là pour pour le
prouver pour assurer aussi la population
nous sommes comme dans une population de
plus de 55 ans et donc je pense que on
peut effectivement penser que les gens
qui attendent déjà
depuis nombreux jours de pouvoir se
faire vacciner
j'ai bon espoir en fait qu'il puisse
remplir nos credo contactée la
préfecture ne sait pas encore si elle
ouvrira de nouveaux créneaux réservés à
partir de samedi
elle en a en tout cas les moyens après
sept journées 272 d'astrazeneca sont
encore disponibles